- So, what did you love about the city?
You've been here for years.
- Yeah.
- So what was... When
you first moved here,
what was like, your favorite thing to do?
- Well, I mean, I think that,
like a lot of New Yorkers,
you just can't believe like,
how close everything is.
Like, every cuisine you'd ever want to try
is just a block away.
And it's also the great
thing about New York,
is that people behave exactly the way
you always hoped New Yorkers would.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
I remember like, early on like,
one of my first days running to SNL
and I had a script in
like a Manila envelope
and an unstapled script
and it just blew away.
And people were walking,
not a single person stopped to help me,
but a lot of them pointed
where the paper was going.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
They would be on their phone
and they'd just go, "There,
it's in the street".
- New York is full of supervisors.
- [Seth] Yeah, just a lot of like, people.
And also, people always say like,
"Do you get stopped, as a celebrity,
do you get stopped in New York much?"
And I always say you don't,
because everyone who lives in New York
thinks they're a celebrity.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Like, anybody here.
- That's awesome.
- [Seth] I think it's great, yeah.
- I was like, that's
amazing, that's amazing.
- When I started,
I remember like, my
first year on the show,
being at a bar in New York
and the bartender said,
"Has anyone told you, you
look like that guy on SNL?"
And I said... I was so excited,
because I hadn't been recognized before.
And I said, "I am that guy on SNL".
And he said, "Shut up".
(audience laughs)
- That totally happens
to me, still to this day.
- Do people think you
look like Kelly Clarkson?
- 20 years in and I'll
be like, "Oh, I am".
And they're like, "No you're not".
And I'm like, "Oh, no, I'm not".
And then they're like, "Are you?"
"Yes I am", "No, you're not".
We have this argument, back and forth
and then I just give
up and I'm like, "No".
- You know, what you should do is,
you should ask for their name
and whatever they say,
go, "No, you're not".
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I'm not as funny as you.
(Kelly laughs)
So wait, so it's, it's all
your years here or sorry,
in all your years, I'm... You guys,
we're going to have to have a fan.
I mean, I am legit,
I'm going to look like a Guns
N' Roses concert in about 2.2.
(audience laughs)
- This is a very... People can't tell
that this is actually carved
out of a block of ice,
to like self-cool the guests.
- I am like a really, I'm
trying to keep it together.
Okay, it's all like a slip and slide.
Okay, okay.
So in all your years here,
what's the most like, New York thing
that you've ever seen happen?
- Oh gosh, the most New York
thing I've ever happened...
This well, all right,
can I talk about cockroaches for a second?
- I'm from Texas, we have huge ones.
- [Seth] Okay, gotcha.
I think the most unique thing
about New York cockroaches
is when they finally die...
- [Kelly] Which they don't.
- They walk into the
middle of your kitchen.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And they do it there, because
they want you to know,
"I've been here, this whole time".
(audience cheers)
- And there's plenty more.
- And there's more, "I'm not here alone".
(Kelly laughs)
- That's the thing I found out about LA.
So, I'm used to cockroaches from Texas.
We have huge ones, but in LA it's rats.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- So, I'm just like out in my backyard
and like a rat, like literally
didn't just run across,
stopped, stared me in the
face and then kept going.
And I was like, where there's
one rat, there's a plethora.
So I'm like, freaking, I'd
take the roaches over rats.
But one of your writers,
Amber Ruffin, who I love.
I love her.
(audience cheers)
She joked, she joked that you got Botox.
Wait, wait, wait, before you leave.
Wait, Seth is on my show tomorrow,
so should I ask him anything?
- Oh yes, there is a very, true rumor
that Seth got Botox, this summer.
You should ask him about that.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- That was a private conversation,
between me and a writer that
was not supposed to be on television.
And it's very hurtful to me that...
I know I'm very, it's a lovely joke,
because I didn't get Botox,
but my natural skin,
looks like it's been
stretched over my face.
- Well, that's amazing.
- [Seth] Yeah, I think so too.
- Congratulations, genetics.
- Thank you very much.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's really good.